[Music]
in controversial greeting-card news
oh no submitted by mr. Sparkle so I
expected a funny greeting company is
getting backlash from teachers what I
did now what I do what they do what I do
wanna do is it the quote that some do
can do something cannot eat oh these are
like my Swan all right so this company
is called love Layla and they're selling
these cards that's kind of guess since
college it's not no it's not that like
oh thank [ __ ] my kid doesn't have you as
I imagine this five-year-old giving this
to their [ __ ] teacher as a ever going
away cart that's a bold move an
equivalent of a youtube comment I hate
comment about the teacher that's true
you know what's [ __ ] funny imagine I
gave this to Isaac second grade teacher
it would have been awkward as [ __ ] when
he was in fifth grade because he had her
no fourth grade game he had her again
teacher in elementary school again oh I
do that that's so mean to give the
teacher like yeah it's like don't tell
the teacher tell the administrators what
if you have a good relationship I see it
as a joke company is aiming it again
it's like if you guys were tight and
it's like I'm gonna miss you thank
[ __ ] god you're not the job yeah like
you follow the teacher
Isaac was my student than me at if we're
cool she gave me this card out loud yeah
and then a pair would never give a kid a
message together after you know I mean
like tell your teacher they're trash
like so it has to be oh I don't know or
I didn't I it's in the envelope the kid
doesn't know what it says
ah I love how it's think [ __ ] my kid I
think that's something I haven't really
heard before
I don't want to talk about God that's
more worse than think [ __ ] my kid
thinking it's just like [ __ ] my kid they
need a comma before that that [ __ ] yeah
I'm saying
you say yeah it's like dank [ __ ] my kid
or thank [ __ ] my kid doesn't have I know
I don't know what's going on bad
combination words but they should have
an explanation after [ __ ] thank [ __ ]
my kid doesn't have to yeah they
actually so they gotta [ __ ] gonna
backlash from teachers taking it serious
and so the card company were saying that
just reaffirms what the card says though
yeah [ __ ] that you don't have this
stupid teacher with no humor those
teachers yeah on a bad day I might cry
if I got the context maybe it's like
think [ __ ] my kid doesn't have you as a
teacher next year and then you open it
up it's a hundred dollar Nordstrom gift
certificate it's like yeah yeah so this
card company do have other cards and
they do have one for the teacher to give
to the parent thank [ __ ] you're not my
student look I don't have to teach your
kid next year that's time oh that's cool
they thought of both markets it's like
an arms dealer selling to both countries
that's in war but they both have to shop
at the same company I can't help but
feel they thought this was gonna attract
a little bit controversy I mean like
making this card in particular how many
are they actually gonna sell well
they've actually sold 10 million I think
any lawsuits from both sides yes the
mother cards that they have like this
one as my child's teacher I completely
understand why you need so many holidays
so they had like other teacher cards
like this one thanks for putting up with
my bratty ungrateful children like my
classmates or with yeah not my oh man
sorry my child is a reason you drink so
have this one I like that was good
that's more self-deprecating yeah I
think the parent knows that the kids
just the [ __ ] handful yeah and then
this last one it's not really teach
sorry I can't raise my kids right but up
the bum no harm done like that sounds
weird but this one is previously made
like headline that would be ah yeah that
sounds rape be to me yeah exactly why I
was like no harm done sodomy nothing
wrong with it I like that shirt name
sodomy sodomy nothing wrong with it
that's a nice little imagine someone
names their kids out of me wait for it
Sodom aiya somebody in Hong Kong one to
me there's ala - out there LA - LA - a
la - when you guys go out and we'll I
guess for yugioh thai cos not in school
yet right but do you ever worry about
how the teacher might affect his brain
because how much time and if for Isaac
do I worry more about other kids
affecting his brain just cuz it there at
the way those kids are getting raised
I'm like [ __ ] so you know how like your
Isaac spends more time maybe with a
teacher than he does with you guys
sometimes right every day he sees them
for many many hours so if it's only one
teacher that teacher can have infect his
brain yeah with a lot of stupidity and
all kinds of things it's all yeah first
six years it's the most important so do
you ever think like like [ __ ] like I
hope I picked the right teacher well I
don't get to pick the teacher cuz he
goes to public school so that kind of
like a gamble um well I mean anytime
that there's luckily he's had really
good teachers like his third grade
teacher was the best that he would give
a lot of like personal stories and Isaac
was really invested and he learned a lot
from him which is kind of cool because
my third grade teacher is my favorite
teacher dude I liked all of my teachers
except for the ones that pinched me
numbers 1 3 5 but yes like whenever
Isaac comes home with something he's
upset about something with this teacher
like I'll end up asking him like well
what happened and like you know do you
feel cos he ends up feeling bad
sometimes so the teachers trying to
wrangle the group and sometimes I feel
like his teacher in this group where I'm
like
come on we gotta keep rolling reticle
and then the kids just don't listen so
I'm like god damn it I totally relates
to her sometimes cuz then he'll be like
can I just said sometimes we don't
listen but then she'll get mad and
she'll give us extra homework I think
that's a good kid that a kid you could
think outside of himself yeah that's
pretty good
no I mean yeah I try to like have him
really observe like the entire situation
not just from where he's viewed it yeah
that's good parenting I don't plan to be
a great parent so I'm afraid for my kid
to be infected by the teacher and then
he says that [ __ ] and I'm watching him
or her and I'm like dad that's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that teacher you want a new teacher
that could actually control the class
you're gonna be like Big Daddy Adam
Sandler's oh yeah you know dad on the
wall with the Sun that was cool that's a
bonding moment right there
like [ __ ] twigs on all the roller
bladers that are going down the hill
that sounds like Joe life lesson don't
be a Bart what's really it the way that
he treats tyka you think that he's
already like that like very loose and
no because we're gonna channel our
parents do you have a good dad or not
yeah I think you're an amazing guy yeah
[ __ ] around too much no at all you're
like I always tell you you're an amazing
dad why do you even make that face I
don't know if I'm [ __ ] around or not
I think that's the role though of dads
in ways playful right to teach play
where's the mom asked to you know yeah
I'm usually the hard-ass yeah yeah I
like snap my fingers and he's like hey
it's party time it's exhausting yeah
energy typically used wood lit would let
the kids explore and be risky yeah
because our level of danger is not the
same but I had a [ __ ] worry work it
was the funniest because his mom worries
hard but his dad worries hard to know
he's a gangster now okay but that's
because they controlled him so [ __ ]
hard
I saw work what happened yeah -
helicopter parents and then I think he
went hell a rebel because he wanted the
complete freedom
so he went extreme thirty-five-year-old
gangster you know hella rebel not to
make another gangster I wonder why his
parents feel about that terrifying so
they still try to control them and then
you know I did his article or I did this
interview on a Japanese newspaper and
then she they left that interview on his
table and then they're basically telling
him how like comparing me to him and I'm
like that is so [ __ ] up dude so
they're still trying to control his ass
and do the same [ __ ] and lecture him and
be a [ __ ] dick ya know I mean we're
friends we laugh about it but we went
through a lot together so I see the
effects though sometimes of a parent
that could be too controlling I remember
his story when I was probably seven or
eight I went with my father and some
friends to the ravine we were to go
around and like kind of [ __ ] around and
have fun similar concept of play right
risk danger exploring and there's a kid
those two tightly wound up and when we
went to the ravine we're just like you
know throwing [ __ ] at frogs or like in
the stream whatever doing kid [ __ ] this
kid got stung by a bee he started at my
father's okay it's finally happens all
the time like whatever
and the kid just started freaking out he
had tears in his eyes and he's not
allergic to bees not any and everyone
else think all the other kids were fine
you know but he starts like tearing up
and saying like am I gonna die and just
having like this freak out and then when
we took him to his house you saw and I
remember this that his parents were both
of a similar nature you know how it's a
be like you're totally fine just like
like you know it's all swollen and these
are kind of scary though if you're
allergic no that's a good no asic no I
don't know I took I don't know he said I
don't know and then it Sagara it's like
let's take you back or whatever but the
parents then we're freaking out he you
just see how that happens that
intergeneration of fear it goes you're
fine
I got like [ __ ] up as a kid and never
once I had my two front teeth just like
knockdown I wasn't go my god meanwhile
this kids like lo be staying in here
dude I got a scar on my knee from my
elementary school like till this day I
[ __ ] bleed like bleeding everywhere
and my mom literally cleaned it off and
did the whole blow it is better it's God
like two weeks ago they refused to
[ __ ] take me to the hospital like I
had to get stitches finally but huh oh
[ __ ] here on my when I when I hit my
head oh I had again that's how bad it
took like to get to the hospital makes
it tough for Beth wait how did it like I
don't go to the hospital now cuz I just
don't do it
oh no wondering like at what point did
they realize like oh [ __ ] we gotta take
when they couldn't probably wanted to
believe me they're bleeding if you need
stitches it's like 30 minutes or more
and there's still blood just kind of
bleeding and bleeding it I'm locked
myself in in my bathroom when I hit my
head on this like coffee table that we
had that had like a little like spiky
decorative it was a ball [ __ ] and I hit
my head and like I was gushing so much
blood and I was [ __ ] terrified you
believe the most from your head yeah and
I was just like no I'm not going to get
stitches I thought because my best
friend had just recently got instead she
was ugly huh for her no it was her head
too like worried like your hair covers
it for her
had buck teeth like stabbed her in the
head with his teeth it was looking crazy
I know so there's quite the buck teeth
guy as it is he's already getting
[ __ ] baked but it's wrong to snagging
things he's telling a story right now
he's like and then my stupid teeth oh
yeah blood oh I don't know I didn't
witness it but then like I was so scared
cuz she was telling me like how much it
hurt that I'm like I don't want to get
sick too so I actually locked myself in
my room for like three or four hours and
I didn't let them come like take me to
the hospital you rather die down that
happened to me in a pool these kids were
like throwing their keys to go dive for
them you know and it threw the keys and
it hit my head and like it just got like
completely like blood just wouldn't stop
with gushing blood sorry you're gonna
stop playing their game and like I'm
like [ __ ] luckily there was a doctor
like like out by the pool like there was
sunbathing and he was like Oh put her
head down you know and they got the
towel like try to apply pressure and the
mom of the kids is just like she didn't
even know this [ __ ]
my mom was there my mom was there
talking to the doctor like he got the
poor girls water like what's wrong I was
nine and I was I just remember I
couldn't play baseball with my team for
a while because like leader scared of
the Sun like damaging so yeah
cuz it cut in my head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]